freunde der sonne herzlich willkommen zu
wie man bullshit erkennt teil 1 die
werkzeuge kritischen denkens bullshit
die pseudo wissenschaft und
verschwörungstheorien fake news
verbreiten sich heute dank internet
schneller als je zuvor
dabei ist das problem an sich ja nichts
neues schild ist wahrscheinlich so alt
wie die menschheit selbst deswegen will
ich heute auf einen klassiker
zurückgreifen wird die macworld von k s
segen und mit karls hilfe freunde der
sonne wären wir heute lernen uns weniger
verarschen zu lassen heinz hesse candle
in the dark ist der untertitel
wissenschaft als kerze in der dunkelheit
wir schauen uns heute das berühmte
kapitel nummer 12 anwirft auf die
petting balloni frei übersetzt die hohe
kunst bullshit zu erkennen vorher
vielleicht ein zwei sätze zu kreissägen
karl segen war ein amerikanischer
astronomen und vieles mehr also er war
vielleicht einer der berühmtesten
wissenschaftler der 80er 90er war hat
viele bücher geschrieben er war im
fernsehen zu sehen er war ein großer und
leidenschaftlicher
wissenschaftskommunikatoren team ging es
nicht nur darum das wissen zu vermitteln
sondern die basis dazu nämlich das
wissenschaftliche denken guter mann
das wichtige und schöne ist ihr müsst
keine wissenschaftler sein und
wissenschaftlich zu denken
wissenschaftliches denken ist kritisches
denken und das kann man sich aneignen
unabhängig von der ausbildung ich meine
klar natürlich lerne ich als
wissenschaftlerin im laufe meiner
ausbildung kritisch zu denken um
wissenschaftlich zu arbeiten aber auch
uns wissenschaftlern fällt es schwer
kritisches denken in unserem alltag
anzuwenden weil das wird ganz wichtig
unser kritisches denken wird immer von
unseren persönlichen meinungen und
erwartungen getrübt wer behauptet
unvoreingenommen zu sein der denkt
bereits sehr unkritisch damit wir uns
leichter selbst überprüfen können hat
keine segel in seinem kapitel der feine
art auf balloni detection eine liste
an tools zusammengestellt so nennt er
das die uns helfen sollen kritisch zu
denken in anlehnung an diese liste habe
ich jetzt für euch fünf regeln
zusammengefasst für kritische sting
bevor ich euch die fünf regeln verrate
möchte ich eine grundregel setzen eine
basis regel sagen wäre die nummer 0
die grundvoraussetzung für jede
argumentation unterscheidet deutlich
zwischen fakten hypothesen und
persönlichen meinungen was persönliche
meinung sind sollten nicht klar seien
hypothesen sind annahmen die aber
logisch oder faktisch begründet sind
die annahme einer hörner existieren ist
keine hypothese sondern allenfalls
fantasie denn dafür gibt es keinerlei
logisch oder faktische anhaltspunkte die
hypothese fruchtzucker ist ungesund ist
eine hypothese denn dafür gibt es
wissenschaftliche hinweise so über
thesen was sind jetzt fakten fakten
müssen wissenschaftlich und unabhängig
bestätigt sein sohn jetzt denkt einfach
mal drüber nach was euch momentan so
beschäftigt oder über was ihr letzter
zeit diskutiert habt dann werdet ihr
sicherlich feststellen sei es ob aktiv
collins nur dies eine gute idee ist oder
welche auswirkung einwanderung auf die
deutsche gesellschaft hat meistens
diskutieren wir nicht über fakten fakten
müssen wissenschaftlich und unabhängig
bestätigt sein sondern nur über
hypothesen und wenn wir über hypothesen
reden ist kritisches denken besonders
wichtig jetzt kommen wir zu unseren fünf
regeln nur eins eine hypothese muss
prinzipiell widerlegbar sein wenn wir
jetzt denken wissenschaftliches arbeiten
funktioniert so und stellt eine
hypothese auf und dann versucht man
diese hypothese wissenschaftlich zu
belegen logisch oder
nein also logisch ist das schon nur
kritisch ist es noch nicht statt die
hypothese nur zu billigen muss man auch
versuchen die hypothese zu widerlegen
für die hypothese der weihnachtsmann
existiert gibt es viele belege wie zum
beispiel die geschenke unterm
weihnachtsbaum oder die vielen bilder
und geschichten so lange wir nur
besuchen geht die hypothese auf erst
wenn wir versuchen die hypothese zu
widerlegen indem man den weihnachtsbaum
heimlich beobachtet die ganze nacht um
zu sehen wer wirklich die geschenke
darunter legt erst dann haben wir die
hypothese wissenschaftlich geprüft das
bedeutet eine haltbare hypothese muss
nicht nur belegbar sein sondern sie muss
auch widerlegung versuchen stand also
gleichzeitig geht jetzt aber wenn eine
hypothese gar nicht widerlegt werden
kann
also wenn es gar keine experimente oder
tests gibt mit denen man diese hypothese
sinnvollerweise widerlegen könnte dann
ist es eine unwissenschaftliche annahmen
beispiel ich könnte jetzt die behauptung
aufstellen wer hier negative kommentare
schreibt ist neidisch das ist deswegen
eine unwissenschaftliche behauptung
weicht diese hypothese überhaupt nicht
widerlegen könnte selbst wenn ich wollte
also nochmal eine hypothese muss
prinzipiell widerlegbar sein nummer zwei
ställe alle möglichen hypothesen auf und
versuchen sie zu widerlegen wann immer
ihr eine behauptung liest oder hört
gewöhnt euch an gegen hypothesen
aufzustellen in meinem kopf auch wenn
ihr euren eigenen standpunkt überprüfen
volt stellt gegen hypothesen aufnehmen
ihr mal spaßeshalber an es wäre kein
fakt dass die erde eine kugel ist dann
wäre es gutes kritisches denken die
hypothese aufzustellen die erde sei eine
scheibe
wenn man jetzt zu alle prothesen hat er
das sind populär der schall wird muss
man versuchen diese hypothesen zu lenken
von unwahrscheinlich bis wahrscheinlich
und das tut man indem man versucht alle
hypothesen zu widerlegen und die
hypothese die den wieder lesungen am
ersten stand hält ist auch die
wahrscheinlichste hypothese während sich
eine flache erde durch viele
beobachtungen widerlegen lässt wie zum
beispiel die existenz von verschiedenen
zeitzonen gibt es für die runde erde
keinerlei physikalischen wieder leben
das einzige gegenargument ist ein
politisches wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe dass da heißt dass sich
die machthaber der welt verschworen
haben und das geheimnis der flachen erde
ausmacht gründen geheim dass selbst wenn
wir die beiden hypothesen ernst nehmen
gewinnt die runde erde war als den
wieder annäherungsversuche standhält
also nochmal zweitens stelle alle
möglichen hypothesen auf und versuchen
sie zu widerlegen nummer drei das ist
die schwierigste von allen regeln
nämlich hänge nicht so sehr an deiner
persönlichen hypothese kritisches denken
bedeutet dass sich deine meinung
jederzeit ändern kann
je mehr du über etwas weist kritisches
denken verlangt eine offene und geradezu
demütigen stellen informiert wenn es
geht über alle argumente alle
standpunkte und die der steht der
versuchung euch mit eurem eigenen
standpunkt mehr auseinanderzusetzen als
mit anderen indem er ihr euch intensive
ihr euch mit den gegenargumenten
beschäftigt desto schärfer wird auch
heuer kritisches denken also nochmal
drittens hänge nicht so sehr an deiner
persönlichen hypothese nummer vier camps
rasiermesser entschuldigung oder cremes
rasiermesser bitte was das prinzip
hawkins rasiermesser ist ein altes logik
prinzip und rasiermesser ist hier
metaphorisch zu verstehen als ein
scharfes werkzeug um unnötige sachen
loszuwerden was machen wir zum beispiel
wenn zwei hypothesen eine beobachtung
gleich gut erklären oder was mache ich
wenn ich verschiedene hypothesen nicht
selbst prüfen kann
dann gilt erstmals die einfachere lösung
ist die wahrscheinlichere das ist
relevant für verschwörungstheorien die
im gegensatz zu flachen erde in sich
stimmig sein können aber so kompliziert
dass sie zu unwahrscheinlich sind sehr
gutes beispiel dafür ist pizza geht also
im zweifel die einfachere lösung auch
bekannt als rasiermesser regel nummer
fünf quantifizieren
wenn möglich ihr müsst euch immer fragen
gibt es zahlen zu meiner annahme gibt es
irgend etwas messbares sprich kann man
hier irgendetwas quantifizieren
wenn ja dann muss ich diese zahlen und
statistiken auch hinzuziehen zu
eine argumentation oder zu meinem
vergleich beispiel hypothese eine
mineralwasser das mit sauerstoff
angereichert ist hilft besser beim sport
als normales mineralwasser für so eine
hypothese muss sich daten hinzuziehen
also zum beispiel sprintzeiten von
sportlern sauerstoff wasser hilft
übrigens nicht beim sport quellen in der
video beschreibung ist jetzt aber etwas
nicht quantifizierbar wie zb die frage
letzte woche sollte man ändern ja oder
nein
dann ist die richtige antwort
automatisch viel schwerer festzustellen
also nochmal fünf offiziere wenn möglich
und willst du jetzt bei alldem nicht
unsere grundregel unter allem die
grundregel nummer null und wir
unterscheiden zwischen fakten hypothesen
und persönlichen meinungen das ist auch
nicht immer ganz einfach dazu sollte ich
vielleicht noch mal ein extra video
machen
aber falls euch noch gute regeln für
kritisches denken einfallen dann seid so
gut teils in den kommentaren mit unseren
freunden der sonne nächste woche gibt es
teil 2 von wiemann bullshit erkennt und
da widmen wir uns auch mithilfe von
kreissägen den häufigsten schlechten
argument nun wie man sie erkennt freunde
der sonne
wenn dieses video rauskommt am
donnerstag den 25 oktober dann bin ich
an diesem abend in berlin
auf der preisverleihung für den
holtzbrinck preis für
wissenschaftsjournalismus sie einfach
ein bisschen viel freunde dieses jahr es
ist einfach ein bisschen viel
manche von euch haben es auch schon
mitbekommen ich gehe da auf der
shortlist ich bin nominiert
und wenn ihr wissen wollt wie der abend
ausgeht folgt mir auch social video da
werde ich euch updaten wir sehen uns
nächste woche bis dahin bleibt sicher